i'm here with ross hi and michelle
park who is a lifestyle expert and going
to teach us something that's going to
make us look at our toaster
differently for the rest of our lives
michelle we're ready take us to the next
level
oh my god look at you guys with your
toasters that's so cute we are so
excited
so i'm gonna make you a toaster
quesadilla so it's super simple grab
any kind of like burrito tortilla
we have stuff here ross and i are in
sync we've got our trays
all ready to go look at you guys all
right so you're going to grab your
tortilla you're going to put one layer
of
your preferred meat i'm going to put
turkey on mine ditto
like imagine you're gonna make a
dumpling okay so you want the edges
to be free so just stick it in the
middle okay it's in the middle thank you
one slice of your preferred cheese will
also go
right on top of that just like that okay
go with it with an american cheddary
type
i could make some sort of cheesy joke
right here but i won't
kind of all right so now we're going to
get some guacamole on there i think of
guacamole as the glue so it's going to
kind of like hold everything together oh
yeah the glue on my thighs michelle i'll
tell you that much
girl same here guacamole team i'm just
like uh spread it who cares yeah that's
what i'm walking about
yeah okay a little hot time god guac and
roll
all right so now you're going to take
your shredded cheese and put this on top
fold the top up like this and then fold
the sides in
so you want everything in this kind of
like
envelope i i kind of got messy with my
my guacamole so let's just keep going
look like kind of
doing like surprisingly well i'm
shocked you know i'm
so do i pop this in the toaster now yes
so stick your little envelope into the
toaster i'm gonna
turn my toaster on i kind of like hold
on to it on its way down okay or you
could just go hardcore
like i was like and then
i let it toast for 20 to 30 seconds and
when it pops out we'll slice it open and
you'll see all the
melty cheesy goodness i will say
wooden tongs because obviously you don't
want to stick metal tongs in the toaster
and
wow electrocute yourself my kid's
grandmother coco
um grammy she always has toast tongs and
they're amazing and they're a game
changer because i am that type who like
sticks my finger down in there and
i always regret it that's a no-go that's
a good hack i like that i need to get me
some toast tongs
i'm gonna
ouch oh it's hot and delicious
oh my gosh i did it michelle thanks to
you
oh wow it looks good i like it when
untoasted
there's one here made for me
this would be like my favorite after i'm
i know you're going sorry that which
means you're getting some fantastic
michelle thank you so much these are
delicious
by the way yes oh my gosh what she said
[Laughter]
thank you so much michelle for coming
here and brightening up our lives and
teaching us such a cool toaster hack
we're very grateful
thank you i'm definitely on my nose now
because i've got a mess over here
now we're out of time and we hate that
because we never want the show to end
so we want to leave you with a little
something that you can take with you
a little thing we like to call the doggy
bag
[Music]
and today it's an old trick that people
have been doing for ages
and i love doing it
it's just i lack consistency and
discipline but
lemon water when i do it my whole life
changes it's incredibly good for your
organs
great for digestion completely cleans
you out
really rust somebody get me a lemon
thank you so much for being here and
we'll see you guys tomorrow
[Music]
you